moi je ne pose aucun prêt là pour
l'instant je travaille avec yannis
varoufakis est pas français
les grecs et l'ancien ministre des
finances nommé des finances de la grèce
au moment 2 mai par exemple sans lara
gros conflit avec la lame à la boe la
banque centrale européenne et le fonds
monétaire international notamment été
notre point identique
nous disons que nous devons nous voulons
porter un projet européen et est alors
le train et tout est en marche et qui
veut nous rejoindre nous rejoignent qui
au lendemain des élections européennes
lundi matin 9h moment les portes de la
commission ouvre les portes du parlement
européen ouvre puissent être portées et
mis en oeuvre à traiter constant par une
nouvelle majorité au parlement européen
ce que nous voulons c'est dire que
aujourd'hui la poursuite des politiques
d'austérité va précipiter la
désintégration de l'europe et je pense
que ce que propose le couple merkel
macron qui n'est rien d'autre que le
prolongement de ce qui se fait depuis 10
20 ans si on ne voit pas qu'il est en
train de désintégrer l'europe
eh bien on est aveugle première chose
mais je pense que la réponse d'un ce qui
serait pardon de dire revenons aux
frontières nationales jetons l'europe
avec ce libéralisme maudit mènera aussi
à une autre forme de désintégration dont
je pense qu'elle n'est pas souhaitable
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
porterons ensemble on y travaille c'est
pas encore définitif on est sur le fond
là aujourd'hui mais probablement s'ils
ne les adhérents et les membres de deux
générations l'approuvent
en juin prochain mais nous voulons
porter un projet qui soit applicable au
lendemain même de l'élection européenne
et qui disent on peut parfaitement
aujourd'hui mener des politiques qui ne
soit pas austérité en europe tout en
restant à traiter européen à traiter
quand ça c'est très important ce que
vous dites à passer à côté ce que disait
ce matin sur public sénat clémentine
autain qui est député la france
insoumise et qui est là bas souligne
justement sa divergence fondamentale
avec avec vous sur l'europe at il dit je
prends un exemple quand il dit on peut
réformer l'europe dans le cadre de ces
traités moi je ne le crois pas je pense
que nous avons besoin de bousculer cette
europe est de sortir de ces traités là
c'est en effet une divergence
j'vous dit clément sinon un autre genre
propose de modifier les traités mais
maintenant il ya la trêve colin
proposeront sur son répondeur est
d'abord veut pas dire ce qui ne veut pas
dire qu'on ne veut pas les modifier un
pan des lunes à maîtriser je vais dû
répondre très précisément
nous nous voulons dire tout ce que nous
ferons à traiter constant et évidemment
désirer les modifier pour par exemple
démocratiser la zone euro mais en tenant
compte des délais qu'il faut aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir changer ses traités je
connais clémentine autain tu as dit je
ne crois pas qu'on puisse le faire a
traité constants donc il faut changer
les traités en l'état qui pensent
sérieusement 12 secondes que l'europe va
s'aligner sur les positions de la gauche
française possible possible mais je
prends ça sera peut-être pas tout seul
non d'accord mais là en l'occurrence si
auch que je comprends bien ce sont nos
positions en tout cas celle de
clémentine autain qui devrait ouvrir sur
une nouvelle europe moi je n'y crois pas
que ça veut dire pour autant que l'on ne
faut pas invité la france a soumise à se
construire un rapport de force même
qu'il vienne mais qu'ils viennent et
qu'on construise un rapport de force où
on s'approche le plus possible à traiter
constants
alors prenons un exemple concret la
banque centrale européenne fait des
politiques dites de quantitative easing
en clair elle injecte de l'argent dans
l'économie européenne pour faciliter les
conditions dans lesquelles les banques
vont pouvoir prêter de l'argent aux
entreprises elles leur assoupli les
conditions dans lesquelles elles prêtent
aux entreprises
cette politique a amené la banque
centrale européenne depuis 2015 a
injecté plus de 2000 milliards d'euros
en europe dans l'économie européenne
plus de 2000 milliards d'euros c'est pas
rien la question est à traiter constant
donc ne peut-on pas fléché une partie de
cette politique de quantitative easing
injection d'argent frais dans l'économie
européenne vers la transition écologique
c'est qu'on me dise surtout c'est la
question que je repose à clémentine
autain abeilles n'est pas là pour vous
répondre oui mais elle peut mais
répondra quand vous l'inviterai après
aimé n comment fait-on demain alors
qu'il ya urgence écologique pour opérer
la conversion de notre modèle de
développement avec cette conversion soit
utile pour éviter un scénario de
réchauffement qu'ils soient à court
terme périlleux pour les générations
futures comme on le fait aussi on saura
patrie va nous on va dire tout haut
niveau national ça voudra dire que on
abandonne
seule perspective qu'il y a d'être utile
au climat c'est à dire d'agir au niveau
européen il n'y a qu'au niveau européen
ne parviendra à changer les règles du
jeu par un amateur de modèle de
développement notamment pour le cognac
j'ai une question à vous soumettent ces
fêtes celle que opinionway a posé c'est
la deuxième question de la semaine sur
les alliances justement et après on
parlera pas justement de ceux qui sont
notamment cités dans ce sondage
vos amis anciens amis du parti
socialiste avec qui conduire votre offre
alternative a demandé au pire opinionway
avec les écologistes très 18% avec le ps
17% avec la france insoumise 16% avec
aucun 54% les français dans leur
majorité vous encourage à rester
autonome même si chez les sympathisants
de gauche est bien le premier choix et
qui est cité c'est la france insoumise à
38%
voilà avec 34 pour les écologistes
qu'est ce que vous voulez comme que je
rêve pour votre tendance et d'être ne
rester autonome non deux comme je n'ai
pas dit qu'on est un grand
bouleversement et que la fed ne faisait
pas très ouverte à d à une union donc et
moins les appareils auxquels moi je
m'adresser ou ceux qui les représentent
comme que les citoyens les les personnes
engagées et objectivement nos jours dans
un moment d'histoire européenne séparée
vous allez diviser les votes c'est sûr
on va dépendre des visions sont des
visions différentes de l'europe sans
doute et on l'avait vu dès l'élection
présidentielle moi je me revendique
comme européen et fédéralistes et je
pense quand on joue je crois en la
coopération entre les peuples
je ne veux pas renoncer à cette idée là
je ne veux pas renoncer à l'idée que
demain même si c'est un parfait même si
c'est libéral par la démocratie on
arrivera à mettre en oeuvre des
politiques de progrès certains pensent
je le regrette d'ailleurs j'entends
leurs arguments que par nature l'europe
n'amènera que régression mais moi je
pense que non il faut créer un espace de
solidarité ces lettres dernière utopie
l'europe un peu vivante et
le pire des choses ce serait de la jetée
aux orties libéral avec maquereau ou
conservatrice avec macro et merkel
ou alors la jetée aux orties
nationalisme au madame le pen ou
souverainiste parce que ce serait le
plus beau projet alors il a été dévoyé
il est aujourd'hui à mon avis il se
retourne contre les peuples européens
il nous reste à mettre de la démocratie
et du sens au projet européen moi j'y
crois à traiter constants est ce que je
le répète pour que les oreilles
s'échauffent pas ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne veut pas modifier les traités
et nous proposons de le faire mais nous
avons un plan a très peur